[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Wow.
Hello, everyone, and welcome
to this exciting Talks
at Google event.
We're so happy to
have you all here.
Wasn't that
performance incredible?
[APPLAUSE]
I'm Bradley Horowitz, a
VP of product management
here at Google.
And it's my pleasure
to welcome you
all to this very special
event with Cirque de Soleil.
And it's about their
newest show, "Volta,"
which just opened in
San Jose, and especially
about the behind-the-scenes
work that goes
into creating a show like
"Volta" and each and every one
of their shows.
So let's welcome
Ron and Bernard.
[APPLAUSE]
RON KELLUM: Over here?
Great, perfect.
Would you like us to sit?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Either way.
RON KELLUM: Great.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Bernard, focus.
BERNARD PETIOT: Oh, OK.
Oh my god.
All right.
First step of casting.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I'm not
throwing away my shot.
Am I in?
BERNARD PETIOT: Yeah.
You've passed the basics.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK.
The basics?
OK.
All right, well,
it's our pleasure
to welcome you here today.
Thank you so much for coming.
And I think we'll just start
with some introductions.
I gave a very brief introduction
of your titles and roles,
but we don't know
what that means.
So maybe, Ron, you could start.
Tell us first a little bit
about your background, and then
a little bit about what you
do for Cirque du Soleil.
RON KELLUM: Great.
Well, first of
all, it's thrilling
to be here on a personal level.
My first job out
of college in 1987,
I actually was across the
street on [INAUDIBLE]..
So it's I'm thrilled to be back.
It's a sports
entertainment company.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: We
own that building now.
RON KELLUM: I realize that.
I was a college gymnast and they
killed our gymnastics program,
so I became a
college cheerleader.
And so the company
that I worked for
was called United
Spirit Association.
They were based here.
And they're now one of the
largest sports entertainment
and corporate companies,
entertainment companies,
in the United States.
And then I went
off to do Broadway.
I performed on Broadway in
several shows for many years
and toured around the country
and the world for 15 years,
stopped performing, became a
choreographer and a director,
worked with lots of big
sports entertainment events.
Like, I've been doing
the NFL Pro Bowl halftime
shows for the last 19 years,
and choreographed Iron Man 2
with Robert Downey Jr. and
directed a lot of theater
around the country.
And then Cirque came calling.
And it's been a pleasure to
work as an artistic director
for the company.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
And just a little
bit-- we'll get into
this more, of course--
but what does an
artistic director do?
RON KELLUM: That's
a great question.
It can be a bit confusing.
What I do, there
is the creatives,
the conceptors of a show.
So they build and
basically deliver the show.
Then there's the
management of the show,
so that's where the
artistic director comes in.
I take on the show as it is.
And what our job is is to
basically maintain a show
that we can do 8
to 10 shows a week
with all the different
changes and challenges
that we have to
deal with in moving
the show, while at the same
time, evolving the show.
We want to make sure that if
the audience has seen that show
a year ago, that if
they see it again--
which we hope that they will--
that they actually will see the
same concept, but new elements.
So that's how we
keep our shows fresh.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: No, I
can't wait to dig into that.
But first, Bernard,
tell us a little bit
about your background.
And what does a
casting director do?
BERNARD PETIOT: My
background, I was a gymnast.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yes.
BERNARD PETIOT: I had a
education in physical education
and then a master's degree
in performance analysis
and a doctorate in cognitive
sciences, which was not
completed because I got an
offer by Cirque de Soleil
at one point of my career.
I've been coaching for
22 years and teaching
Montreal University 18 years.
And now it's 20 years
at Cirque de Soliel.
And I was hired to basically
implement a whole system
in Montreal at
the headquarter so
that we could sustain
or help the show
to be sustained in
their performance,
and also help the
creation of the new shows.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: No
shame in dropping out.
Larry Sergey-- it's what we
do here in Silicon Valley.
So let's get into some of
the behind-the-scenes magic
that you guys are responsible.
For so Ron, every Cirque
show is imaginative,
from the storyline
to the costumes
to the themes to the
acrobatics and performances.
So how is the theme
for a show decided?
Like, what is the process?
Where do you start,
and how does it
evolve into this
amazing production
that we can go see in San Jose?
RON KELLUM: I think the
best way of answering
that is that it starts with,
where are we in reality,
in time?
Right now we're dealing
with pop culture.
We're dealing with
instant gratification.
So what Cirque has,
I think, done so well
is take what's happening
right now, or in the past,
and bring it forward.
So the idea right
now with "Volta"
specifically is really
about acceptance,
and that every single
person's individuality
is very important.
We've sort of found
ourselves in this world
of capturing and
creating the narrative
and sort of hiding behind
what we want people to see.
What's very special
about "Volta"
is the [INAUDIBLE] let's get
back to who we really are
and how uniquely special
every individual is.
And that's what
our show is about.
BERNARD PETIOT: And
that's the reality, also,
of Cirque de Soliel
is that diversity.
And it starts
supporting, let's say,
the idea, the initial idea.
Then it starts,
also, with casting
who you would select, actually,
for the various acts that you
have to build around this
big idea and this concept.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
What is amazing to me
is that the show is, at
once, extremely topical
and on point to what's
happening in the world.
But it's also timeless and spans
cultures and spans generations.
So it has this universal appeal.
And it does all of this sort
of without being on the nose
and over the top about it.
So it's an amazing
art to sort of convey
all that without lyrics
or necessarily verse.
It's all done and conveyed
through choreography.
BERNARD PETIOT: Yeah,
and it's interesting,
because when you look at that
reality of creative reality,
is that Cirque du Soliel
is really good at inviting
creators, people that have
an experience of background,
and inviting them around
the table, around a team,
and then managing
that environment
and supporting them
so that they go
through the journey
of the discussion
and the development
of the ideas.
And when you add on
top of that, the team
would be around 20 to 25 people.
And part of that,
maybe four or five
are only from internal creators.
And everybody else is
from outside and invited
for that specific project.
And then you add
after that the artists
that are coming from various
background, various culture,
also.
OK, you saw this actor
coming from Japan.
In "Volta" you will
see also the BMX people
that are coming from
this urban activity that
is also free in
spirit and supporting
the idea of the show.
And they are contributors
to the journey of creators.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah, I
imagine they have to be,
because you can't
basically say, let's
get someone who can skip
at six skips per second
and then find out
if that's feasible.
You sort of have to be in
dialogue with what's possible.
And I want to talk to
you about that process.
How do you survey all
that's out there, you know?
So it's a big world and
there's, from Japan to San Jose,
there's a lot of
interesting things going on.
How do you keep a pulse
on what's cutting edge
and what's possible?
BERNARD PETIOT: It's two ways.
There's the traditional
way that you
will find in the casting
process, which is basically,
in our case, is going to
the various circus festival,
doing the audition, as we
normally do in casting,
and also--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: When
you say circus festivals,
there is like a
conference circuit for--
BERNARD PETIOT: No,
those big festival, you
know, where you can find,
actually, circus professionals.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: You're going
to other circuses and poaching?
Is that what you're telling me?
BERNARD PETIOT: And then we're
also going to competitions.
And then I have a
specific agreement
with the International
Gymnastics Federation
so where I can go to all of
these worlds, and Olympics,
and so on, and then
keep that relationship.
Because what you have
to understand is nobody
has an obligation to produce
the talent for Cirque.
We have to find a way--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
There's no farm team,
really, that's sort of--
like you're saying, maybe
some of the things you do
is look at adjacent
things, like BMX, right?
And--
BERNARD PETIOT: And
so there's that way,
but also there is
the technology.
There is YouTube.
So we scan through the YouTube.
And we also have our web.
We have also
created a community.
And then we're
extending now and we're
looking at new strategies and
sort of open source, whereby
people could actually inform
us of some specific talent
that we haven't discovered
yet, or a person that
has a craft or something that
would be interesting for us.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So
we're very honored
and glad you use YouTube.
These folks built
it, some of them.
And it is amazing.
How do you feel about little
snippets of Cirque performances
ending up on YouTube?
Is that OK so long as it's
appropriately tagged and--
BERNARD PETIOT: It's very
interesting, because it's
so key in terms of an indication
of what's happening out there,
what's on YouTube, that could
also serve as an inspiration.
But we need to go further.
We need to meet these people.
We need to see if they do
is sustainable over time.
See, if you take a
touring show, it's
about 360 occasional
performances.
If you go to our permanent
show, it's 470 times.
OK, so you need to
select people that
have the ability to sustain
that level, in consistency.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Reliable, repeatable.
BERNARD PETIOT: Absolutely.
Yeah.
RON KELLUM: And it's
actually really exciting,
the YouTube platform, because
for someone like myself,
who is creative always and
having to evolve a show, that's
why I do a lot of
my research, where
I go find these amazing artists
that don't have the platform.
If they're living in
a small rural village
in a small country
that doesn't have
the access to this
performing world,
we can find them because
they can post instantaneously
what they do.
And it's amazing what we find.
It also helps us to stay
innovative, excuse me.
BERNARD PETIOT: And yeah,
and the other thing, also,
because I am responsible
of a team that
is doing equipment and
performance development,
and then we scan what's
happening out there.
And then we use that
as an inspiration
to see if there is a new tool
or something that we think,
OK, we say, if we
modify that, if we go
and push it a bit further,
OK, if we meet these people,
then if we establish a
project, then we can actually
push the performance.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: This is one of
the questions I wanted to ask.
How much do you focus on
augmenting the performance
with, whether it's a
bicycle or a wheel?
I've seen all kinds of things.
Like, could it be
a robot or bionics?
Like, is there a limit to how
far you would apply technology
in service of the performance?
Or do you like to
keep it a little more
grounded in the human
aspect of our own bodies?
BERNARD PETIOT: I'll
start, Ron, if you want.
Actually, yeah, looking
at the technological part,
it should be there
to help to enhance,
to ensure that it's sort of
giving a new opportunity.
It's not replacing the human
because fundamentally Cirque du
Soleil is based on
that human presence.
And basically, we've ventured
ourselves working with robots.
And it's very interesting
because we created, also,
an act with, let's say, a kuka
robot, comic act with that.
So there is a lot
of possibilities,
as long as it's integrated
in the performance
and it's kind of
helping the performance
to even look better,
or to surprise
with something
that you would not
expect as a physicality
of the relationship.
RON KELLUM: And I would
only add that it helps
with the theatricality of it.
I think as long as it stays
in that space of, wow,
we're evolving.
We're raising the consciousness,
while at the same time
inviting people into this story.
I think it's a great
partnership and synergy when
we accomplish those things.
And I think it helps
us stay on the cutting
edge of entertainment,
which is really exciting.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Let's talk
a little bit about the tech,
because a show like
"Volta" doesn't
happen without a tremendous
amount of back office
technology.
We sort of see the end product,
but the synchronization,
the lights, the
music, the performers,
can you speak a little
bit about what's
sort of going on
behind the scenes?
RON KELLUM: Well,
you know, I have
an amazing team-- our artistic
team, our technical teams,
it is critical.
It's really like
air traffic control.
There's one person
who's our GSM who's
calling a show in real time.
And literally, the
conversations are cue to cue.
For example, we're using high
level technology and music
together.
And what we're doing is if an
artist is going for a trick,
for example, and
they're on the BMX
and we know that we want
to coordinate lighting,
video, at the same time,
music with the accent
of this incredible trick that
the artist is about to do,
many times the artists will
miss the trick-- not fall,
but they don't execute it
in a way that they want to.
The artists will indicate that
they're going to do it again.
So we're actually performing in
real time with live musicians.
And we will get a cue from our
general stage management that
says, we're going back to
measure for our bandleader cues
to the musicians that we're all
going back, lighting and video,
so that we nail it
at the right moment.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
So in real time,
you've got to be able to skip
back four measures and-- wow.
BERNARD PETIOT: And in
terms of performance,
it's interesting, also,
because we are using
a lot of motors and automation.
And there is this
relationship between the guy
that is controlling the motors
and then the performers.
Let's say strap, as
an example, where
people will fly up in the
air and then come back
on the stage very, very
smoothly, that rapport
and using this instrument of the
motor and all of the technology
is very important
for the performance.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Is
there a single conductor?
Is there someone
with a baton who is
sort of running that timeline?
Or--
RON KELLUM: That would be
considered the general stage
manager, but there is
the musical director,
the bandleader.
And they're in
great communication.
We also use a signal
that's very pedestrian now,
but it still works.
It's the red light, green light
system, for all departments.
So technically and
musically, automation,
every department knows that--
and even the artists when
they're performing
in real time--
if we're not set up and
all elements aren't safe,
there is a red light in four
different places onstage.
And until they see the green
light, no one goes further.
So that's how we
also communicate
with the artists on stage.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Amazing.
And I assume safety
is paramount.
I mean, what you're
doing is no joke.
And you know, you
guys must put that
at the forefront of all thought.
BERNARD PETIOT: Yeah,
and safety, for me,
when I look at it from
a global perspective,
it starts from the
first casting steps.
I mean, we're
selecting an individual
that has a proven
ability to perform.
In other words, they're
not developing themselves
from the scratch when
they arrive at Cirque
and then start from there
with that specific profile.
And after that, we go through--
especially in creation, we
go to all of these steps,
OK, in terms of making the
appropriate progression,
testing every steps in
every component of an act,
and then ensuring that
we do that in training.
Then after that, we do that
in show condition by the time
it ends up on the stage.
And then you have
the same thing, also,
with integration, where you're
taking all of these steps
to control the security
aspect and the safety aspect.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So all
Cirque shows are moving.
I think some of them
are very dreamlike
and sort of touching
deep parts of ourselves.
There's a little bit of a dark
side to them sometimes, right?
Like, it's not all
Disney and fairy tale.
There's sort of some--
it's a show that
can be very adult.
Can you talk above
that shadow aspect
or sort of the blend of the
uplifting and positive message
around tolerance, but also
sort of the darker side?
RON KELLUM: Yeah.
I think that it's
really important to--
it's sort of that
commentary on reality,
that our shows sort
of push the envelope.
We make people think.
We make people walk away
going, I'm not sure.
And I think so often
in entertainment we
want it to have a happy ending.
I think sometimes it's really
important as storytellers,
as innovators, that we leave
a space where you're going,
what was that?
Or what does that make me feel?
Or how am relating to that?
Because then out of
that, we're pushing
everyone's consciousness.
I think that's what Cirque
does brilliantly without being,
we're just going to be esoteric.
It's more about, let's put
on this dreamlike reality
that we walk away going,
I felt like I had a dream.
And we go, right.
Now, what was that
dream for you?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Yeah, I really have
had that experience as
you're leaving where
you debrief with everyone.
What did you take away?
And it's fun to sort of see
how personal the experience can
be for everyone, and how
different people pick up
on different aspects of that,
which just really speaks
to the richness of the show and
how much thought goes into it.
Tell us a little bit
about the costuming,
because that's something that
is integral to the performance.
And the costumes we just
saw are absolutely amazing
and almost hard to
parse, you know,
there's so much going on there.
How are the costumes developed?
And is that, again,
from the inception?
Or is that done
later in the process?
BERNARD PETIOT: No,
it''s from the inception.
And again, we go through
that with the creative team,
so we'll find the
costume designer.
And the costume designer will
work with our costume shop.
And within the costume shop,
there is an R&D department.
And basically, they will
go from [INAUDIBLE] ideas.
And then they will test
various possibilities.
And all of the
craftsmen, the people
that are used to
create our costume,
will contribute with
the creator finding
the appropriate solutions.
What we have developed
now with the technology
is we use the 3D print
in order to scan and so
on, which actually
accelerate the process,
or allow to test the idea and
see if it's going to work.
And so all of that
process is combined
with the whole team in
terms of the training that
is being done, and
also all of the costume
that is being developed.
And every steps leads to
decisions and acceptance
of what is being designed so
that it fits with the concept.
And that was all
done in Montreal.
And then after that,
when it's on the road,
then Ron is continuing
the journey with everybody
that is being replaced, and
actually-- or even the costume
that you can talk about.
RON KELLUM: That's right.
So once we get the actual
wardrobe on onstage,
then it has to be durable.
It has to be sustainable,
because we're moving--
we're doing upwards of 360
shows a year, 10 shows a week
sometimes.
You have to make sure
that it's working.
For example, the double dutch
team that was out here today,
that's neoprene.
And it's also the
same kind of texture
that you would find in a
diving suit, a wetsuit.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Wow.
RON KELLUM: And also, they can
only be worn on one artist.
What a lot of
people don't realize
is once we create these shows
and we cast these artists,
to replace one
artist is thousands
of dollars of investment.
Once we find this
young artist in Peru,
for example, we go
through immigrations.
We go through medical.
Then we go through trainings.
And then we go through the
costuming of that one artist.
So by the time they get to
us eight weeks later on tour,
there's been a huge investment
once they put on that garment.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I would
like to see you guys going
through the TSA pre line and--
there must be some fun
you guys have in airports.
But also, the dry cleaning
bill for that must be terrible.
RON KELLUM: Huge.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
If you can even
find someone to-- but
these are the things
you have to think about.
So not only do they
have to be sustainable,
but you have to have
sort of enough inventory
you can rotate through them--
BERNARD PETIOT: Yeah.
And some of the
costume, also, have
to be designed so that they are
integrated to the performance
so they become also a
performance component.
Let's see if you have to
wear something on your head.
And if it's too heavy,
then it will influence
the mechanic of the movement.
Or if you need some
protective areas,
then that has to be developed.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Costume's
probably the wrong word,
really.
I don't know what the right
word is, but it's integral.
RON KELLUM: Absolutely.
And also, there's
another layer to it
is that we have inventors
right here on site with us.
For example, on our team,
we have a wardrobe--
our head of wardrobe, Karen,
who is absolutely amazing.
We're also dealing in
real time when something--
a piece of wardrobe
malfunctions or--
they're having to be
innovators and recreate.
This past week we
had a great reality
where we had to restructure
a piece of the wardrobe
that the conceptor conceived.
So there's a lot of
checks and balances.
But she was smart enough and
fast enough with her team
to redesign this element,
also come up with a prop
that everyone goes, we should
sell that in the [INAUDIBLE]..
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Bonus.
Do you guys have--
I talked about
the airport thing,
it made me think,
like, are there
any rituals that you guys have?
Do you travel as
a crew like all--
how many did you
say, 300 some people
in a production like this?
Do you hang out
before and after?
Or do you sort of meet
onstage and disperse?
What's the behind-the-scenes
culture of Cirque like?
RON KELLUM: It
truly is a family.
I mean, it's a circus culture.
And the tradition is real.
We are family.
Typical days for most
of us start at noon.
Our technical team will
arrive on site at 9:00 AM.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
That's just like us.
RON KELLUM: Right.
Exactly.
You spend your
whole day together.
We eat together.
Literally, we have three
chefs that travel with us.
We have a full--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
That's just like us.
RON KELLUM: We're the same.
That's why we're
working together.
And you're together.
All the artists train
every single day.
We're evolving this show.
And we typically end
our days around 11:00.
And we travel
together, most of us.
So yeah, it's quite intense.
There are no secrets.
And if there are, good luck.
BERNARD PETIOT: And
that's the model
of touring as you have now
with the big [INAUDIBLE]..
But also, there is
arena shows that
are even faster in
terms of their change
of different cities.
And then we've got,
also, the model of Vegas,
which is a resident show.
And then people come in and out
and they go through their house
after that, which is
also a different model.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: How many
Cirque shows are in production
at any given instant?
BERNARD PETIOT: This
year in operation
we have more than 20
shows in operation.
And then for 20 and 19,
we will have nine premiere
that we will be spreading
throughout the year, which
is the biggest number that
we have ever done so far.
So we're all nervous about it.
We will be delivering
a show in April
and then a new show also in
China and then one in Germany
and so on.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Incredible.
That's really prolific.
I mean, it's enough to put
on one show like "Volta."
But to do synchronously
as many shows
as you were doing,
it's really stunning,
the scale of which
you guys operate.
BERNARD PETIOT: Also, the
thing that you have to look at
is when you have the cast that
is currently doing the show,
then you've got to look
at how you will establish
a system that will allow the
turnover, the replacement.
And currently it's
about 14% a year
that I have to replace, so over
1,300 artists that is currently
in performance on our stage.
So--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: You
guys really are Google.
You're dealing with attrition.
You're dealing with hiring
and finding suitable talent,
you know, the best of the best.
A lot we have in common here.
So tell me about Cirque's
role in the performing
arts altogether.
You really did come out
of a circus tradition,
but you really created something
that is unlike anything else,
even to this day.
But have you moved the industry?
Is there evidence that
you've sort of changed,
both everything from
theater to circuses
to other aspects of
the performing arts?
What is the sort of greater
historical context of Cirque?
RON KELLUM: You
know, what I would
say is the influence that it's
had in the world of artistry.
I mean, you can't
go to a concert
nowadays without some
influence of Cirque.
When I do a halftime
show, I'm enrolling
that aerial acrobatic level.
I mean, when you see the opening
ceremonies of the Olympics,
Cirque is there.
And its really
set the foundation
of how far you can go in
the entertainment industry.
Even in theater, you know, the
Broadway model has changed,
which is very exciting.
So we've made our mark,
You know, and I think the goal
always is to stay relevant
and to stay current, and really
keep telling great stories that
move people.
And I think that as a result
of that, everyone sort of jumps
on board.
BERNARD PETIOT: We've
influenced a lot also
what I would say the
physical practice.
So there is now a big wave
of innovation in young people
that are basically being
influenced by us in developing
new acts or new ways
to actually present
their craft and ability.
So that's quite interesting.
And this is very also
interesting from my group
and casting and looking
at these new disciplines
or these new performances
that are emerging.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
One thing that's
hard, given the
ridiculously high bar you've
set for yourself,
where do you go next?
I mean, obviously there's more.
And you sort of have
covered the world
in terms of number
of performing shows
and in residence in Vegas.
And then they're sort
of moving the quality
and nature of the performance.
Are there other things you're
thinking like new modalities?
Like is VR a possibility?
Can I sit on my couch
and experience Cirque?
Like, where do you go from here?
BERNARD PETIOT: It's a
really good question.
It's a big, big challenge is
how do we reinvent ourselves,
or what kind of other avenues
that we could look at.
In fact, we're
developing new product,
like CREACTIVE is
an example that's
been done in the Club Med.
And it's basically in
participation in nature.
But using technology to
VR, also, we use that
and we've created possibilities
for people in Vegas
in some of these permanent
show to experience
the show from the inside,
using VR, as an example.
And then we're
venturing and exploring
all sorts of these
possibilities.
But broader than that,
also the company,
even though it keeps
its core product, which
is human-based circus
space as an example,
then we're broadening.
As you know, I mean, the
company has been bought.
And then we've also
acquired new groups that
are also doing performances.
The works, as an example.
There is more in
the magic world.
So then we're looking
at these areas, as well.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Anything to add, Ron?
RON KELLUM: Yeah, you know,
what I would say is that just--
I would say that the
company is always
looking for the new
innovation and innovators.
And I think for me
today, when I came here
on campus for the first time,
I had the same excitement
that I have when I go to our
headquarters in Montreal.
You just watching and
seeing these things that
are happening that you
recognize that people
are changing the way we
do things right here.
And I think Cirque
is the same way.
When I walk into the
wardrobe department
and I see the wardrobe with
the technical department
and they have this
beautiful dress that they're
creating that will bloom
in front of an artist--
the audiences eyes.
That's very exciting.
I think it's just about
forward innovation
and not trying to outdo
ourselves, but keep
pushing the envelope.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
So for each of you--
and if you don't have an
answer, that's OK-- but is there
something you've
been itching to do,
like some element
you want to introduce
or some direction you want
to take Cirque that you're
willing to share with us now?
And if you'd rather surprise us
next year, we'll wait and see.
But is there something
that's personal for you
that you want to
sort of see happen?
BERNARD PETIOT: From a human
performance perspective,
which is my core
responsibility, there
is a part of that integration
of all of the illusion world
and the technological world
and the human performers
that actually we're
pushing to another level,
and especially with the
show that is coming up
in Orlando soon
with Walt Disney,
I think we will have something
that will be surprising.
OK, so you were all
invited to go there.
I think we've pushed it--
the frontier of some
of the performances.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Exciting.
RON KELLUM: For me,
it's very personal.
I feel like we've gotten
so far in innovation, which
is very exciting all of us.
And we were led
by our smartphones
and all of those things.
And when I go to a concert
or I go to an experience,
I recognize that we're really
quick to pick up our phones
and capture the moment.
For me, as a baby
of the theater,
I love when people put
them down and they're
impacted by what we do.
So on a personal
level, I want to help
keep creating theater, a
circus, that is pulling people
in and away from
their technology,
while experiencing technology
right in front of them and art
come together.
That's sort of my own
personal sort of ambition.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
I think, as I understand
it, that's one
of the themes of "Volta" is
a little bit how technology
can become a barrier
towards human connection.
It's something we
think about a lot
here in terms of digital health.
We both create the
phones, but we also
want to create the tools that
let people use them responsibly
and interact at a
very human level.
So we very much resonate
with that mission.
And we're appreciative of
the work that you're doing.
We're going to turn it
over to some questions
from the audience.
And you know how we do it here.
There's mics in both aisles.
And in order to be efficient,
it would be helpful
if you guys could line up.
Start thinking
about what questions
you might want to ask.
And as we do that, we will
invite some of the performers
back up on stage to do
that in just a minute.
But before we do that,
is there anything else
that you guys would want us
to know about your process,
about Cirque, about anything
we've talked about here that we
didn't touch on?
BERNARD PETIOT:
From my perspective,
I think I have to
commend the work that
is done with the artistic
director and the whole cast
when they are
actually on the road,
because that first step that we
do in creating the show which
is contained in terms
of time and money
then is being after
that supported,
let's see, for 10
years as an example.
And then you have this
the surrounding system
that is supporting
the individual
and creating the best
possible environment,
either from a
training perspective,
from a performance
medicine perspective,
from a performance safety,
and then from an artistic eye.
I think that's one of
the thing that it's
important to understand all of
this effort that is being done
in order to allow
these performers to be
at their best every
day, considering
there is a lot of variability
and the show is never the same.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
I really, again, draw
parallels to Google.
We work really hard to
make an experience which
is effortless and seamless and
instant and magical for you.
Behind the scenes,
there's so much
work that goes into
creating something
so delightful and simple.
So we definitely
appreciate all that you do
and all that the performers
do to make that possible.
Ron, anything you want to add?
RON KELLUM: Yeah, you know,
and thank you, Bernard.
I think when you see
these amazing artists,
their level of commitment
is unbelievable.
I mean, they're world class.
And when we find them and
they come into this culture,
we really try to create this
family, this level of support.
If you were ever to come
backstage at one of our shows,
I'm always amazed that after
a show, or maybe two shows,
it will be 10:30, 11:00 at night
and these artists are still
training.
It's unbelievable.
They will walk right off
stage with our coaching team
and in real time on
the playback watch
their performance
and self-evaluate.
That level of commitment
and dedication,
week after week, I think that
so often we get caught up
in the performance of the
show and we walk away from it
and we got wowed by it.
But there's a real stamina
and a real dedication
that I think we sometimes
forget because we
might make it look too easy.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Is that
sort of a practice you do,
a post-mortem, sort of review
the show, see what worked,
what didn't?
RON KELLUM: Absolutely.
But you know, it's driven by
the artists, believe it or not.
Our job is to manage and
maintain show quality.
But their commitment is--
they actually push
us, their expectation
and what they need to deliver.
And they are frustrated
if we-- for example,
we were in San Francisco
a couple months ago
and we had high winds,
and to the point
that we have safety
protocol in the big top
that when those gale force
winds, if they get up
to 60 miles an hour, we have
to decide, are we going to cut?
The artists want to keep going.
They have that show
must go on reality.
And our job is to help support,
while at the same time protect.
So it's a fascinating dichotomy
that we're working with.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
Wow.
Let's invite the
artists back up.
[APPLAUSE]
RON KELLUM: You want
to introduce them?
SPEAKER: OK.
Hello, guys.
Nice to meet you.
We are skippers from "Volta."
How was our act?
You guys enjoy?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
We are from Japan,
some are from Japan.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Anyone--
well, they're watching on video.
SPEAKER: Oh, that's all?
Thank you.
RON KELLUM: OK, great.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Do you have
names you want to share or not?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
My name is [NON-ENGLISH].
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Cool.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Nice to meet you.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK, let's
get to some questions.
Green mic first.
AUDIENCE: One topic of
conversation always at Google
is trust--
trust with our users,
trust with our peers,
trust with our executive.
Unless I miss my
guess, trust is sort of
fundamental to the Circus world.
Are there things that
you do within the family
to help you build trust,
either at the head office
or on the road,
things like that?
Like, are there tricks that
you use or things that you do?
BERNARD PETIOT: Maybe I
can talk with that process
that we use when we're
developing an act.
I'll take it as an example.
You know the teeter board,
you know where the people
are bouncing from both sides.
In Montreal, I am
in charge of what
we call the training before
they actually go on the show.
So we are inviting people coming
from the trampoline world.
And we could have
maybe people coming
from France, from the US,
from Russia and et cetera,
and they will meet
together right there.
And then they have
to work together.
And teeter board is
a very dangerous act.
So what we do in order to
make sure that actually we
create that trust is we go step
by step in terms of processes,
having them to go through
all of the basics,
all of the language.
We also provide--
I may have two or
three translator
there to provide the appropriate
communication between all
of them.
I will have an artistic
coach, an acrobatic coach
at the same time surrounding the
entire environment to make sure
that they develop their own
dialogue and communication
and they understand each other
in terms of who should do what
and when and what kind of
reaction they should have.
And they will go through weeks
of training and developing
that.
And then step by step,
OK, then the coach
will step back, step
back, and then transfer
that responsibility
of the group to manage
the performance, to
dialogue between themselves,
to brief and debrief.
And that's what
Ron was saying is
we develop, also, that
debriefing culture
as part of the process.
So then when the
performance is done,
then they will revise it, look
at the video and the replay,
and then talk about
it and self evaluate.
RON KELLUM: Trust is number one.
I mean, it's
unbelievable how critical
these checks and balances are.
And we take them daily.
For example, when we have to
put a new artist into the show,
they will never come to
us and go right on stage.
We have to do a full show
validation in the reality
that they're going
to be performing in.
Just a change of the lights
can change their world.
And if they don't
understand that, they
haven't had a chance
to prepare, it
can become a challenge for them.
So absolutely.
And that's how we build that
into our systems and balance.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH].
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: This is a
slightly different question,
but these artists who are at
the top of their game and rock
stars in their
respective disciplines,
sometimes rock stars can
develop rock star attitudes
and be a little bit
diva-like or Prima Donna.
[LAUGHTER]
Have you ever-- like, do you
have to work on that, too?
Like, have you asked
people to leave that can't
get with the family--
we all have strange
uncles, but is
that part of this, sort of
making sure that people really
do have the right attitude,
as well as the right talent?
RON KELLUM: That is a
key part of the job,
as well, is really maintaining
the family environment,
that there is no--
if you think about
Cirque de Soleil,
there is no name other than Guy.
You know what I mean?
You don't hear of the
artist performing in--
Cirque is the stars.
Cirque is the brand.
We want the artists to
understand that we all
bring a contribution to it.
And there are times that
some artists can't fit inside
of this bubble.
And we respect that
because we always
encourage people to
find where your light is
going to shine the brightest.
That's the most important thing.
If it doesn't feel
like it's bright here,
we will support you in finding
that place that's right.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That is a
great way to give feedback.
Thank you.
We're going to use that.
BERNARD PETIOT: It's a
very interesting question,
because if-- and I look
at the casting at large,
we've got circus
professionals, we've
got people coming from the arts,
singing, dancers, and musicians
and so on.
But we also have more than
30% coming from sport.
And from sport you
want to be the best.
You want to be on the podium.
So when you leave
that culture and you
come to our
environment, then you're
becoming part of that family.
So you're engaged to
develop that ability
to actually sort of
personally disappear and be
a contributor to the show.
And we ensure that
this process is also
part of what we do in
Montreal to make sure
that these people that
we are coming with that
see gold medal at
Worlds or Olympics,
they will put that here.
And now they will adopt the
culture of Cirque du Soleil.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Amazing.
OK, yellow mic.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you for
coming and talking to us.
I was wondering,
how much time does
it take from the time
you conceptualize
a show to the time it opens?
And within that time
period, how much time
is spent in choreography and
training and things like that?
BERNARD PETIOT: It could take
from the initial team and then
the selection of
the stage director
and a couple of other creators,
the director of creation
and so on, from
two to three years.
Then that is
basically developing
from the idea the whole concept,
and through that journey,
is also identifying, OK,
the different profiles
of artists that will be needed.
And then, so that we can
proceed through the casting,
because casting
takes a long time.
And sometimes also it's also
being influenced by immigration
and all sorts of obstacles.
And then after that, we
have the training period.
The training period,
let's see, as an example,
the big top that we will
be producing in April,
then we started the training
period last September,
last year in 2018.
And then from fall to December,
then we only did the training.
And at the same time,
then the costume
were designed,
developed, and so on,
and all sorts of other
technical aspects
were developed, and
equipment, and so on.
And then January, then
you start the rehearsal.
And the rehearsal
continues up to the moment
that we transfer in April,
in March, under the big top.
And that whole rehearsal
is being done in Montreal,
in a big, big studio.
That's so we could
do that inside,
because it's cold in Montreal.
And then after that,
we transfer in April.
And then we will be
opening, let's see,
this new show
"Allegria" by mid-April.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Great question.
Yes, green mic.
AUDIENCE: I watched
the show last Saturday.
It was amazing.
So I have a question.
So I remember in the
show there is an artist,
I think her name is Danila Kim.
She was dancing along on
the stage with her hair tied
and the hand on top.
That part was very different
from the rest of show.
So from the perspective
of storytelling,
could you help me understand
how this part fits
the rest of the story?
RON KELLUM: I don't know
if I got the question.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
From the perspective
of sort storytelling,
how does that element
fit in with the
rest of the show?
Because she found it
to be very different.
RON KELLUM: I love that
you asked that question.
The idea, the
conceptor is always
thinking, for us as
individuals, we put on a mask
or we put on our armor every day
when we walk out of the door.
And the goal is,
take off the armor.
Take off your mask.
And then fly higher.
So when we get to the part
of the show with the hair
suspension, it's all
about fly as high
as you can and let it sort feel
like you're in outer space,
where there is no gravity.
You know, that's the
idea of hair suspension.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RON KELLUM: Did that help?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Beautiful.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for coming.
I can imagine with the degree
that safety is important
and the degree that all of this
is transpiling in front of us
live that it can be
very difficult to make
the go or no go call.
And that's something
that the general stage
manager, the performer, is
that ever a difficult thing
with this feeling of
the show must go on
to be able to negotiate
what is possible
and what's impossible as things
go, as people miss tricks,
as people say, I can
do it the next time?
RON KELLUM: Great question.
100%.
There is that moment
where we all have
to make a collective decision.
And I always say more
heads together are better,
because when we get to those
moments where it can be
we've pushed too hard.
Fatigue could be setting in.
Or the environment that we're
in just not sustainable, we do
have to make that decision.
The show does not go on.
It's something
that we don't like
to do because we respect
that our audiences come
from all over to see a
Cirque de Soleil show.
We respect that many times,
when someone comes to our show,
it's for a 50 year wedding
anniversary, a birthday
celebration.
They're very
special moments what
gets people under the big top.
So we want to deliver.
But at the end of the day,
safety, safety, safety.
And we take that into
consideration every day.
BERNARD PETIOT: And
the phase of creation,
it's interesting, also, of the
safety management, especially
when we create an act.
We will develop the equipment.
The equipment will be
tested, engineered,
and then we'll also
develop the act
by selecting what
is sub-maximal.
We're not in a competition.
So we're not trying to
do the one best one time.
We're making sure
that the content
is being selected so that
it's within the resource
of that individual.
And then we will also
test these over time
to ensure that when it's
integrated in the act, then
it will be sustained.
So in fact, I
mean, your question
is very, very interesting.
And it's a preoccupation
of mine right
from the onset of creation.
How far should we push?
Obviously, we're doing circus.
So there is a risk there.
And then we're creating
every processes
that is possible to ensure that
not only we select people that
are really good from
the onset, but also we
make all the progression
and the steps
to verify and validate
these performances
under various circumstances
up to the show
condition with lighting
and music, and so on.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Yes, green mic.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for coming out.
My question is, when there's
a creative difference
or disagreement, how
do you resolve it?
BERNARD PETIOT:
First of all, you
have to look at the globality.
So we are inviting
these creators
to come in Cirque du
Soliel, but we're also
assigning what we call
a director of creation.
This person is to
manage the environment
and manage that dialogue.
And sometimes this tension,
it's not nice every day.
There's sometimes all
of these tensions.
And eventually, this group will
have to come up to an agreement
or take an option.
Obviously, the stage
director has a lot of power
because he wants to protect
the basic or the intent.
On my side, I have an equipment
designer and a performance
designer.
And as soon as it steps
into the exposure of risk,
which could be life
threatening, then that's
where the buck stops.
And so then it will be a no no.
Everything else after that
is open for discussion,
open for dialogue,
open for conversation.
And obviously, as you go
up to the [NON-ENGLISH],,
there will be time by which then
you realize that this is not
possible, or this
could be dangerous,
or this will not render what
you're looking at in terms
of the expectation
of performance.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Just in terms
of decision making process,
do you have a
traditional hierarchy?
Or do you have a whole-ocracy?
Is there someone whose job it is
to make a call about what's in,
what's out?
Like, that's well-defined
and established?
BERNARD PETIOT: Somewhat,
although it has a little bit
of a holistic approach.
When it was [NON-ENGLISH]
as the sole owner,
I would have to say to being
present that he would say, OK,
I will give you
another three weeks.
And if you don't convince me,
then that's the end of it.
Now that has changed
a little bit.
[NON-ENGLISH] is
not there anymore.
So the director of creation is
exercising that responsibility.
And then eventually
the executive producer
may at some point
also exercise that.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Got it.
OK, we have time maybe for
one or two more questions.
I wanted to prioritize if
anyone has any questions
for the performers.
We didn't just bring you up here
to look at you, although we do
enjoy looking at you, as well.
But if there's a question
for the performer,
could you come forward?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you for coming
out here today.
I'm very curious kind of in the
process of developing your act
or in training
this act, was there
a particular
difficulty or a story
that you'd like to share about
kind of where you ran into kind
of a crossroads and you had
to make a decision, how you
overcame that to create the
wonderful performance you had
today?
SPEAKER: We are kind of
like new skipping team.
We have been together
for two years.
Then we have a specific
trick each other.
Then we create the
act, what you can do,
what you want to do in our act.
Then we talk each other.
Then we-- that's important
is how we connect each other.
Like, we use the ropes.
Then how are you turning?
That's a very important.
If someone is slowly and faster,
we cannot jump in the ropes.
That's the very hardest point.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So the main
problem is the damn rope.
OK, I think we have
time for one more.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is-- thank you
very much for visiting.
I have a casting question
that's mainly for Bernard.
I'm wondering, when you see
a performance, whether it's
on YouTube or in person or
whatever other venue, what
makes you think that maybe that
person would make a good Cirque
Du Soleil performer?
And at that point, do
you have a job interview?
Or what happens?
Like, how does that happen?
BERNARD PETIOT:
That's interesting.
That's a really good question.
Basically, the way I will
answer is within my casting team
I've got scouts that are
specialized in various areas,
either be in dance or
in musicians or singers,
and so on.
If they see
something on YouTube,
then two things will
come to their head.
One is, would I select
that person because
of what is being done
reaches that level
that I'm looking for?
Then they're more in a selection
mode based on their specialty,
so I've got people
specialized in trampoline,
in tumbling, in
acro, and et cetera.
So they'll take that decision,
or they will look at that
and they will say--
they will basically
because of their education
and their background,
they'll say there is
an indication here
that there is a
potential that if we were
to tap into what I see, that
we could eventually push it
further.
So they are going to be
more on a detection mode.
And then when they are
in the detection mode,
they will present that to
the new creative group.
Or then we will venture
on our own decision
to meet these people,
to spend time with them,
to get to know them better,
and to look at any opportunity
to venture or
collaborate together,
so that because of the
indication of the potential
or the detection
of that possibility
that we can eventually
venture and develop something
with them.
RON KELLUM: I would
just add one last thing,
because this
happened in real time
and I love how our worlds
are colliding today.
So then Bernard's team will then
send me a particular profile.
So I'm looking to replace
an artist right now.
So I get them, they're
uploaded onto a platform,
sometimes YouTube.
But yesterday, in real time.
I talked to three
different artists--
one in Tel Aviv, one
in London, and one
in New York, all on Google
Chat, because all I got to see
was their performance.
So we asked them,
can you jump on?
In 30 minutes, I
was able to identify
who my next candidate would be.
So that's how we're working
together, which I love it.
I didn't even think
about that till now.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Awesome.
On that note, there's
sort of one group
of people I'd like
to thank before we
thank Cirque, which is our
own behind the scenes staff.
This magic of scheduling this
event and lighting this event
and producing this event
doesn't happen by accident.
So let's take a moment to thank
the people behind the scenes
at Talks at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
And most of all, let's
thank the amazing performers
and production team and
executives of Cirque Du Soleil
for doing what you do,
not only for coming here,
but for doing what
you do in the world.
Thank you so much.
BERNARD PETIOT:
Thank you very much.
RON KELLUM: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]